er vor genau einem jahr änderte sich die
welt im aartal buchstäblich über nacht
wir alle haben die bilder der zerstörung
noch genau im kopf sie die wassermassen
damals städte überfluten autos und
häuser einfach mitreißen mindestens 186
menschen sterben in den fluten und noch
immer werden personen vermisst aber wie
ist es heute ein jahr später die opfer
müssen nach wie vor jeden tag kämpfen
viele können immer noch nicht in ihr
zuhause oder leben in unsanierten
gebäuden und das nach einem jahr
wasser überall wasser am 14 juli 2021
verwandelt sich das kleine aartal in
rheinland pfalz in ein tal folgt tod und
zerstörung
aus einem kleinen fluss der im sommer
nur 60 zentimeter tief ist wächst
innerhalb weniger stunden ein reißender
strom mit bis zu zehn metern höhe eine
schier gewaltige wassermengen rast durch
das kleine tal und reißt alles mit autos
wohnwagen häuser menschen
es ist eine beispiellose katastrophe die
sich im aartal abspielt eine katastrophe
mit ansage
denn der deutsche wetterdienst hatte
bereits am tag zuvor vor extremen
unwettern gewarnt aber die behörden
reagierten zu spät
alarmsysteme versagten politiker versagt
unterschätzten die gefahr oder drücken
sich vor frühzeitigem konsequenten
handeln das landesumweltamt ruft nur die
zweithöchste warnstufe aus hohe
hochwassergefährdung noch um 18 uhr 25
erwartet das landesumweltamt einem
wasserstand von nur vier metern eine
fatale fehleinschätzung mit fatalen
folgen
134 menschen verlieren ihr leben kinder
frauen männer menschen werden aus ihren
wohnungen gespült auf der straße
mitgerissen
20.000 menschen verlieren alles in
dieser nacht fast 9000 gebäude werden
zerstört oder beschädigt das
beschauliche aartal versinkt im wasser
und chaos ein ende der verhängnisvollen
nacht werden 1300 menschen vermisst
die größte katastrophe in deutschland
seit 60 jahren die am 14 und 15 juli
2021 über das aartal und das südliche
nordrhein-westfalen hereinbricht
eine katastrophe die in ihren ausmaßen
vermeidbar gewesen wäre und deren folgen
noch immer nicht behoben sind weil nur
ein winziger teil der hilfsgelder
aufgrund von bürokratischen hürden
bislang geflossen ist
auch ein jahr nach der verhängnisvollen
flut leben menschen noch in
ausweichquartieren und noch immer werden
menschen vermisst
[Musik]